this chair feels very good on my lower
back
for mine i'm the odd man out dude yeah
black cheers matter here
that's right thank you uh my energy dude
i'm i'm trying in the gym my energy is
out there i mean let's be honest you've
never had a ton of energy
you know like you've never been like an
energy ball not an energy bomb
well i wouldn't describe it as like an
energy i guess what am i trying to what
am i trying to say like i don't know
just lifting i just
i just feel so slow that's
lethargic yeah that's that's dude it's
coping my girl was trying to bump uglies
like a few days after i got my negative
uglies yeah you know what i'm talking
about oh make the beast of two backs
red penny night yeah yeah yeah little
saxophone
i could not i couldn't do anything no
you're thinking about red penny night
what do you mean
his girl's trying to have sex yeah get
it up oh i could get it up
but i just couldn't i could i had no
like it's weird because i had no idea
no drive no drive but so was this during
code or after this was after like i
had my negative it was like we were like
three days after
couldn't you have just laid them like
girl you know i don't have the lungs for
this
dude my lungs are shut i don't want to
just lay
in the middle of my coughing fit i had
sex in the middle of my house
did you really yeah i had sex you got
down i got down the hallway there's
[ __ ] no way and he was
you were out for 19 days it was but you
were able to [ __ ] bump ugly the whole
way through
really i don't get why you couldn't
though i just no but just ladies
look at me in the gym it's just me my
secret ask me my secret
goblet squats and oysters oh gosh now
this comes from the guy who was
ten times as sick as you were with kofi
you were so sick
you should have heard him go i mean like
like i thought i was i was like oh i got
i got permanent lung damage but i still
don't have my energy i still don't have
like nothing i think that's gonna take
normal it's normal yeah
you're stronger than jimmy you're good
on deadlift yeah now mark
has fallen off a little bit my i don't
know what happened mark went to costa
rica
yeah you drink the water he came back
and we didn't want to post it again but
he
he failed on he failed yeah he couldn't
get it up now papa kept going to 550.
yeah he with the fight yeah
i'll call you [ __ ] you call your band
yeah i went you can't do that cool let
me let me just put more weight on it
yeah
550. yeah and he had he was struggling
with four seven five yeah he has like a
backhand someone is back i think he's
costa rica
i think he's saying he's all bad mark i
don't even see this he looks a little
smaller since he went to costa rica
does he yeah you think so he just did
now he just went like this
yeah he's that big of morphier where the
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah
the guy like mark all you have to do is
with the guy like mark all you have to
do is listen wait
that's it that's it did you do you
change your diet why
you look thinner he's like that's it
dave right there
dude he's gonna he would cry but then
you just probably crying after he said
oh yeah
he's listening it might be the shirt
doesn't matter so he should wait you did
your hair your ponytails down the sides
yeah
yeah yeah you got a haircut too yeah i
think he trimmed his hair up yeah i
think
he's different now maybe what he's
eating out of the water i don't know
since came back he hasn't been as strong
hasn't been as strong well he probably
wasn't trying to all the same no he was
yeah he's out there like doing the
whatever they do in costa rica he's like
carrying [ __ ]
rocks and [ __ ] down the beach damn weird
huh
brenda got all the strength now i know
yeah you you called for deadlift day
and me and mark were just like i text
them monday night i said yo
tomorrow deadlift tuesday get your mind
right everyone's like yeah
then we get there i'm trying to toss on
big boy weight and it's like
that's kind of a big way yeah oh big boy
what what you saw in the video how many
how many uh how many things i've seen
every one of the videos
i usually send to them and say
because i'll get a video just generally
morning i wake up and it just says
i can kill you with my bare hands that's
it
well if a man dead lifting 550 like that
he comes out
go back to the first picture oh that was
that was mark that was mark
it was mark's profile go to mark's
profile
hello hello mark carl hella he's looking
a little small look at him
the middle picture right there okay that
was all right let's get some scent
that was it that was the other day that
was when we did bench
that hair is simply out of hand
yeah he looks out of control he keeps
knives he shreds it you know
he shreds hitting now um don't be mad at
the girl either yeah don't be mad but
also don't flex like that for your
female you know
she can flex like this not a good pose
don't do the double
don't do the double not a good pose yeah
it is yeah what's wrong with that
i'd rather see her like this maybe you
want him up yeah that one's like
you know with your shoulder i don't know
yeah i think she was just following
mark's lead
probably that's all probably i mean he's
i mean
mark's cast look he's still dude he's
gonna have varicose veins
i would imagine what's that it looks
like i would imagine you're the old
person and they have like
it looks like a tree branch yeah
no i don't have him you don't have that
no no bubba come on
dude remember that's right yeah yes
psoriasis yeah oh i don't have varicose
veins
oh very good so you say i'm one of the
few guys in my age who still has hair
down there you ever see
do a study guys in their fifties lose
their hair on their calves well the the
guys that's what we're talking about
daddy i don't have varicose veins yeah
that's it right there no no that's not
very
yeah it is no it's not that's yeah it's
because i'm very thin and shredded
and you can see my [ __ ] container
i've had that snows no i don't know
those veins don't touch my
this is take your fingers off my tongue
no it's varicose no that's not very good
it is bring up varicose veins varicose
veins
yeah i don't have your [ __ ] grandpa's
legs dude yeah you do
take it back right now and i'm dead
serious nice nice
pale skin so you can see my [ __ ]
veins no you got a little
that's a very bronze fan you [ __ ]
dude that's what you have right there
forgotten i don't have a bunch of
veins what some parts of you no i do not
look at those veins yeah that's fair
question you get rid of that
you you don't actually have to be awake
no you can have an operation
there's a way you can they you get
operations but that's not a good
operation like on game of thrones season
six where the
the rock boiling for me you gotta cut it
gotta cut it off
just gotta yeah i mean the show's
[ __ ]
japanese well you don't know but is that
such a deep reference
you're not you're not doing it even i
had to kind of and i was like oh yeah
yeah you're talking about don't worry
about it he didn't ruin anything for you
no dude
that brother got killed which one jason
momoa killed that brother
viserion yeah he dumped that goal all
this he's like
he's like where's my crown yeah yeah
yeah what's the [ __ ] you know what this
language [ __ ] to learn
as an actor and be like serious about it
you have to like you got to translate it
could there be a worse way to die though
dude they melt all the gold and then
it's melting
molten lava gold over your head and you
just [ __ ] you just [ __ ] it's a
really bad
she didn't care no she was like she was
like he's no dragon
yeah dragons don't die by the way why
would she care though that's her brother
who tried to pimp her out
yeah he didn't remember how we're out he
didn't wear out this is her like yeah
she got a baby out of it yeah i think
there are other ways that they used to
play
how far do you feel she's gorgeous she's
such a duck i'm in love with her oh wait
do you
want to see it right in the dragon and
[ __ ] yeah oh really this big black
dragon
yeah big black dragon yeah okay
black black black
yeah i know i'm just saying that you're
the mother of dragons like there's no
other
hard to go no she could probably figure
so well you want to disappear for a
while uh her
real name is amelia clark she's just as
gorgeous i've seen a real livestream
dude when i was working for e i worked
the
shoes or oscars different right no she's
smoking hot dude she's the mother of
dragons and she's but she's short she'd
pull her up right now
small she's short but you know who's
[ __ ] huge she got a little booty on
her too
um but you know who's huge you know the
you know the female warrior the the
knight which brianna
has the same haircut like me what
brianna tart yes well she's a giant
dude well you know she's 6'3 that's
correct i've seen her in person she's
16. she's a giant
she's going to ask she's adorable
actually yeah she's cute
with dark hair a lot she's gorgeous is
she english too
yeah that name is very english how old
is she now
i think she's in her early thirties dude
oh
and they just she probably she's
probably like game of thrones just has
her tits
out all the time all the time only for
season one she didn't do it any season
after that it was a body double after
really yeah people doing that yeah yeah
because you know as an actor you know
you know the shame shame yeah that one
was that her real body
no i think she had a body double thirty
four
because i'm balls deep in game of
thrones you don't but how would they do
that i don't think so what do you mean
like they show her face walking you
think you just i think she did an
interview where she said it was a body
double
i think that's right can i tell you why
i think it's a real body why
because
your body wasn't as flattering as what
when there's someone pissed some [ __ ] on
her for shame shame your body was
ridiculous
i think if you watch it again you might
change your mind i just watched it two
nights ago her
you i think your bad eyes and i look
great and i think her body's ridiculous
i have very good eyes but i'm i'm
bringing up your body whose body would
it be oh my face
spoiler for you close your eyes close
your eyes close your eyes a spoiler no
it's just
she's one of my favorite she's one of my
favorites of all time just
when you so hot they're sexy and then
there's beautiful
she's so and she's gorgeous i love
everything about her so i'm i'm her
biggest fan she was in 300 remember she
played the world
chess mom the incest mom yes yeah the
one who [ __ ] your brother
yeah yeah yeah lena how's she been lena
heady she's banging beyond i i think
that's my that might be that's her
bring bring up uh walk of shame game of
thrones and they're gonna show
they're gonna show her i just respected
her so much i respect her so much for
being naked like yeah
context but there is a spirit it is so
intense it is it's one of the best
scenes of all time
is it possible that she did like her
scenes and then they had body double for
days where they needed just like her
back
see my mind's like my girl was saying
that she thinks that she looks like
she she told me she thinks it's her body
but you know when they show like
everything yeah she
like they kind of mess up because you
can see she's wearing something over her
vajayjay mm-hmm i believe that she did
this
i don't think it was a bodybuilder but
the jj jj i
i yeah she i don't think she i don't i
do not believe that this was a body
double i think she really scroll down
and took a lot of balls for her to do
this man this is not easy
she's gorgeous though yeah but it's it's
also your naked
oscar is on on on look at her real body
chin what's her name
lina if you have body dysmorphia like
most of us that would be and that'd be
hard to do
would you take your time off for game of
thrones what's up
all i'm saying is that she was an older
woman like that she's like in her 40s
and that's hard for a woman in this dude
i'll say this
game of thrones or yellowstone i will
i'm sorry so she had a body double my
bad so that's the one of the big
tits um okay so she did it
wow doesn't mean her naked body wasn't
also in there right
i don't know because it could be like
what if she had a body double for can i
can i just say it's an
actor like when you do that it's it's
that's the body double shape
it's a big like money thing and it's a
contract thing and it's hard to
negotiate those deals and it's easier to
get a body done negotiate a body level
yeah it's it's it's easier to do it with
a body double because you're
you're getting into like a lot of money
when you do that it just becomes a whole
thing
she's so pretty it's uncomfortable for
everybody oh you know what else i
watched over i forgot to tell you
that was [ __ ] hilarious uh
no deadpool all right great i know i'm
late on
all this super lately there's two of
them now right
i love the second one too i gotta be
honest they're all wait what what when
did the first one come out
hot second ago hot second tj miller
right yeah oh yeah
he came up the name deadpool oh he did
well in the in the movie and oh yeah
he's like
deadpool who's gonna die he's like i put
my money on you yeah yeah no that movie
[ __ ] hilarious great and i heard ryan
reynolds really had to
yeah he worked with other people yeah he
had to like but i heard he had to go
through some work you know he wrote it
years ago he wrote like 10 years ago and
marvel was like no we're good and then
he did it himself
and then marvel signed off on it what he
made a trailer or something like that he
made a trailer but he wrote the movie
and tried to sell to marvel and like no
deadpool's not going to be a success
then he did himself
that's just funny he's so talented he's
such a good actor
he's great before deadpool he was
actually cast in the x-men
films as deadpool but they did a shitty
version of it
and he loves the comic book so much that
he actually wanted to write his own
movie that's how he had pulled
is that is that a lot like is that
pretty close to the comic
yeah his version of deadpool is very
accurate yeah yeah he's like he's like a
funny kind of witty guy
yeah damn that's sure if you remember
turok
they knew the movie of turok what is
that because
he was it's like if you mix jurassic
park and tarzan really
yes sick sounds really bad bring that
[ __ ] up
dinosaur man we got a man dragon right
here so
yes there's a video game too that's it
uh right i'm already here at the comic
book dude
he's showing a video game never is
terrible terrible what do you oh is he a
dude fighting dinosaurs
oh i had that coming oh he's basically
conan he's basically conan
that's mark harley that's a bite off of
conan in in dinosaur worlds yeah that's
conan dude
that wouldn't be lit as [ __ ] no no he's
conan yeah wait this is a movie or just
a
dude this was a comic book i'm saying oh
from kona he stole from robert e howard
he's connected
well he's indian though you know yeah
but i mean okay he put some feathers in
his hand you know uh
you know this brian probably but you
know caveman and dinosaurs didn't exist
at the same time right yes we have
that's right everybody in here knows
we all do that yeah where's this coming
from i'm just i want that to be very
clear
you just want to make that announcement
because i just i don't know if you guys
know but paleontology is one of
brennan's uh yeah hobbies it's just
because you know in movies and stuff
they have caveman with dinosaurs
and [ __ ] it was never i don't know if
there's a movie that like that but i do
appreciate what you're saying
there's a ton of them it might be what
might be not though though there is
a movie definitely pixar the minions
there's that
caveman that's right and that's pixar
now after dinosaurs 65 million
65 million years dude when you're
watching game of thrones though and you
realize how much damage those [ __ ]
dragons can do
it's like god i wish dragons were right
the dragons they didn't even pop out yet
it's a little bit you know i think i'd
like to know how old the author of fire
is because that's
a little bit like what happened to
europe
after world war ii like germany looked
like
dresden looked like the surface of the
moon so like a lot of them all
right yeah so so for a guy like this at
72
he has a memory at least born in 48 so
three years after the war
you know he would have been five six ten
when they were still ruins
when people were still you could still
see people it was still part of
being english oh he's not even from
england i don't know that's from bayonne
new jersey
[ __ ] yeah america oh i thought the dude
i thought hollywood was
in the area it's based off the true
story of
families fighting in england though oh
okay yeah yeah and he just added the
dragons
but that age you know that's what
happened in europe that's what happened
to london a lot of places just complete
yeah but it was like a dragon came in
and burned it yeah but there wasn't
imagine if there's real dragons so wait
hold on what happens
what's what's the difference like what's
the difference between a lord and a king
because they t they keep the lord would
be a lord would be out there
i know that i'm a lawyer lord you're
gonna call him straight
i don't know if that's true because you
have to be [ __ ] lord sir he has a
sentiment i swear to god
listen to me right now it's your
official title lord shock okay that's
cool
and you're going to have this that's an
internet horse should be referred to me
as lord brendan i will not because
you're not a [ __ ] i'll rip out your
yellow teeth listen [ __ ]
i'll come at you right now i'll slap you
in the face and i i never did that to
to the lord if you're a landed
aristocrat a gentry owns land who has
family that goes back
owning land yeah you're a [ __ ]
there's a lady ladies and lords lord
okay you're an aristocrat
society there was called it was called
the great chain of being so there was
god
then the king then the aristocracy okay
right and the aristocracy typically i
believe those were the
ladies and lords who owned land yes and
then there were the
merchants you know then there were the
serfs the people that kind of
worked the land and were allowed to live
on the land and yeah essentially
and then there were that was pretty much
it and then there would be that's how
that's how their society works yeah
and you never ever one of the things
about england is yes
certificate of registration lord brendan
this certificate entitles the signing as
stipulated above to
english title rights the title rights
assigned shall be lord brendan schaub
the sign this is not signers lordship
titles and duty registered under the
house
of peer point archer you're basically
lannister the name is permanently
filed that doesn't say that that doesn't
say that
i don't believe that says that and
you're and you're gonna be my [ __ ] i'm
not gonna be
i'm not [ __ ] no you're me the old nice
[ __ ] and by the way that's politically
incorrect apparently i'm a little pissed
i'm a lord and i say what goes you're my
small [ __ ] and you're witty
and a lord do you want me to laugh do i
am i called in to make you laugh yeah
yeah
so i gotta be called you're a jester i
gotta be a jester
no you'll be my uh my right hand you're
the the lord's hound what do i have like
a concert
or whatever what do i have to do
whatever i want dude
i'm older dude my feet and stuff watch
his feet
throw it throughout when i [ __ ] in the
bed you throw the stuff out you need to
[ __ ] the bed
with the lordship titles with all rights
and privileges attended to oh shannon
lord shaw dude that's amazing listen you
can't just
own property in england maybe everybody
who owns a house is a lord
you got it no no you have to be my
family find out what it is
what family where your side my mom's
where is it
what where is it where is it don't go
where
no
[Laughter]
there are three ways to become a lord or
lady marry someone who has inherited the
parcel of land and gain the title
through marriage thank you
purchase the parcel of land from the
current owner and have
the title bestowed upon their landowner
that's what i got
up the stairs to the house of commons
who the [ __ ] is this guy who had the
title bestowed upon
and what is it where's the land that you
wanted my
i won't do it look at that
it makes me so mad what is it
i'm basically a lannister i'm a lord
yeah so you have to say
and as the lord i'm gonna summon you to
the black wall
why you're you're one of the black i
don't i have family and stuff i don't
want to go to the black woman i don't
care dude
no more sex you're going to defend the
calabasas wall
how there's nothing to do they're just
coyotes and it's
and i don't do well in the sun dude i'm
a lord pretty so it's legit remind me of
that yeah i forgot about that
old [ __ ] who's this who's this
this is kyle jonas
for halloween dude apparently jon snow
is
you look like a vampire i'm not afraid
of
what the [ __ ] is your cape dude that is
not
jon snow dude no oh
an emotion
now you got to say well did you guys go
out after that yeah wait was it a
finale party for game of thrones no it's
halloween i just took a big
sword to the bar and was just double
fist and white claws like that
and did any chick think i could answer
that question
i took a 70 over at home by myself that
night yeah i was like can i put my sword
in the trunk to like just get in here
dude
but why but why did you have a bowl cut
john smith
you don't have a bowl and his hair is
kind of like curly
can anybody can ask you this question
did anybody at all
even once that night go jon snow
yeah there's a birthday call i guess
it's a very vampire vibe right it's like
a weird game of thrones
because yeah you you put eyeliner on i
did yeah
or or it's the one that the vampires off
up twilight twilight
yeah oh yeah you're like you're like the
vampire around saying i want to suck you
did
say something like this um lords and
ladies
dinner is served lords and ladies dinner
is served
dinner is served i'm more i'm more bossy
like inspired
brian lords and ladies lords and ladies
oh that's pretty dinner is served dinner
is served that's pretty good i like
knight's tale a lot growing up so i i
watched that but
martin lawrence no how dare you what's
nice about that was heath ledger
can you not do an english accent your
mother is english i know i grew up with
it
try it it's just not in my wheelhouse
let your mouth go but i can't hey
look at me no back to the back to the
game
give it a shot no i love that you sent
this cal
was anyone dressed as any other game of
thrones people
that makes him you put you on uh you're
you're not i can't do it so there's no
people
give it a shot no i promise it's not
there's there's no way to go
you know what you're actually like the
kid is going to choke
english i'm from england i'm from
let's try being aristocratic at the
moment yeah you're lord you're the lord
say this hey i am a lord hey as your as
your lord
and you're gonna kneel shut the [ __ ] up
you're gonna kneel you're using violence
to silence me right now dude
the water's not that cold and i don't
obey by your weird
american rules i'm gonna hit you i'm
gonna hit you i'm gonna [ __ ] hit you
i'm gonna
strike you say that no i will strike no
i'm lord i don't have to do anything say
that how crazy i'm the lord though
it's okay you're changing the subject no
it's not you're if you're a lord if
you're an english lord
at least play the part dude yeah you you
can do it yep for sure here's the part
dude kneel to your lord i'm gonna force
you to kneel
you i would never take you i'm gonna
take your stupid head and i'm gonna
force you to kneel dude
i'll blow my neck and i'll fight i'll
fight that's fine i'm gonna kick your
knee out
you're gonna make him bend the knee
don't you don't kick his knee out the
[ __ ] he needs something he never he
needs some damn needs
well that's the only 57-year-old 54.
54. what did you say 50 something i'm
54.
how dude how good does josh thompson
look for he says he's 44. i don't know
why he said he's older
he's 42. he's 42. yeah you weren't that
impressed
no you're like oh he's 14 yeah he's 42.
looks like he's 42. he's a great looking
guy
very strong jaw you don't think he looks
42 i don't know he's got
great hair but he's i don't know oh cat
you went to my
uh chicken hot spot last night yeah last
night uh
my sister steve and i went to owls
because we were craving hot chicken we
were in the neighborhood
it's so [ __ ] good what did i tell you
it's the bun the
right the swastikas were great uh i did
medium to start out because you were
talking about how spicy it was so i was
like okay
baseline let's go medium definitely
could have done extra hot but it's
really [ __ ] good did you see the sign
for the
like super super hot one oh yeah they
have the l.a hot where you have to
sign a waiver like what did everybody
get uh medium
uh my sister and i got medium and then
stevie got
mild stevie could handle the medium
steven
what's the point
on the miles add some seasonings yeah
steve is on romaine
sweet potatoes chicken and some rice
yeah and you guys
you guys went late at night could you
text me late yeah it was like
10 11. steve will stevie step out of his
bodybuilding diet
oh now that he'll do it on the road yeah
he's with me and then he lives with my
sister and i absolutely could you guys
cook
uh because we just eat we eat like
normal people yeah so every now and then
if he sees me eating something he feels
like he's
he's being left out so we'll take a bite
or something but that uh
owls compared to howland ray's it's i
mean it's up there it's up there i think
i'm more likely to go to al's just
because it's not as annoying
to try to get it's a cool vibe in there
too right it's like
yeah what's so special about the bun
it's all about the bun
[ __ ] soft brioche bun really it's a
really good one what's he what's he uh i
know i like to do this
what's he uh what's stevie up to right
now do you think right now
he is eating a bowl of
sweet potatoes with avocado
maybe a fruit parfait and then he's
gonna go to the gym in like 30 minutes
i eat that every thursday so me my son
he gets no
jitsu it's right where he goes fujitsu
we walk from there he gets ice cream and
i get that
oh do you get ice cream from the uh
stuff like that it's good ice cream
that's delicious brian do you eat stuff
like that
not a lot i've been really i've been
really different
lately i've been super weird about
eating
yeah like i just eat really clean and i
don't even drink gay
god dude
as your lord no i'm your lord don't say
it again let me ask you
lord i'm gonna need you to bend the knee
and eat some [ __ ]
vulnerable so don't say it again let me
just try all right
yeah so what i do and don't i won't all
right you can't say no because what i'll
do is i i try to eat like i'll eat like
some lean meat
dude please i'm asking is it
i'm trying to listen i'm trying to
listen
like hey i'm trying to get my diet out
man let him fit
it's my favorite thing in the world so
funny i love
stupid [ __ ] like that my buddy for a
while
you'd be talking and then you were like
even like kind of getting a little
personal
he would go he'd go shut up
it's so obnoxious but daisy was better
yeah he's such a hard interruption
it's so good i'm literally like well now
i've been eating really clean
i just you know not a lot of fats just
lean meats to some veggies
my girl got so mad last night we're
watching game of thrones oh can i tell
you about my mom
she's going she's like she wanted this
gift card and she about then she's like
i don't want and she's doing this long
story and
she's like are you listening i go no i'm
not i'm not
and i went this is the stupidest story
i've heard all day
i dude i'm trying the stupidest story
i said in what in what world do you
think i would care
about your mom shopping and using gift
cards dude
and what what you know me oh yeah
like in what world would you stop game
of thrones
season seven don't tell me this terrible
i'm proud
i'm trying to read it it's like a hype
scene too i go you stop game of thrones
for this
horrible story dude there's
my girl i'm trying to read a really good
article and my girl starts
you like the reason you start telling
his story yeah and i'm listening to his
story and then i remember in i'm trying
to listen
i don't know where it's going because
she's like and then there were lake and
then we were on the lake
and i go and i remember because i'm not
listening but i remember
a faint memory of when she started the
story
i i go i think as i'm trying to listen
and not follow i go
i think she started the story with
i had a dream and so i go
after three four minutes in which is
excruciatingly long i go wait
is this a [ __ ] dream and she goes
yeah i go
never tell me about a dream you have can
you imagine if you
told if you called me today like dude
last night i was dreaming
stop stop stop i don't care we can
barely don't waste my time
things that did happen yeah there's
going to be a point to what did happen
right
you ever see that [ __ ] that's what you
said you got chocolate
hey fellas how many of your girls tell
wonderful stories
nobody the one you're raising you really
oh no you don't believe that yeah
you know you know who's the king of
[ __ ] [ __ ] with you and you don't
even know jimmy burke
oh yeah where where my friend's wife has
got
she's i guess she had all these opinions
he didn't agree with like she was just
talking about
i don't know for the story it was like
everybody should be wearing masks and
like stuff it was just
he could tell everybody was getting
annoyed so he started going like this
he he'd start he'd go
so so everybody's like this and then she
says another thing and he goes
it was just drawing no [ __ ] dying
like
and she didn't know what he was doing
hey hey what did jimmy burke do that
lady with big tits on the on the train
remember he's like
ma'am it's because you're big stupid
tits no that's because
no he he what he would do he would do
really weird things like that where the
woman got off
she she was this really nice woman and
she's about to she gets off the
the wrong floor in the elevator she is
on the wrong floor
and she gets back on and she goes i
don't know why i did that
and jimmy who's the nicest guy in the
world
goes he goes like this he goes i know
exactly why
you do and he goes yes it's because
you're a goddamn [ __ ]
and she goes and she started laughing
and he started laughing so [ __ ] hard
because
it was such a ridiculous thing like it
was a mistake
it's not because you're a god excuse
you're a guy because you're a goddamn
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why uh [ __ ] he did this to his
uncle his uncle was a gangster in fact
on page six after he died i think it was
pete vessier one of them
one of the famous journalists in new
york said the last tough guy
in brooklyn died today and his name is
artie burke and he was
carried a blackjack he was kind of a he
was like kind of the muscle for the
irish mob and you know
[ __ ] yeah and there are legendary
stories about him legendary
in fact was that was a box jimmy's uncle
fought um yeah
anyway he was he was a real legend and
and
his own brother said to me his own
brother jimmy's dad said bad guy
bad guy like a real like a real gangster
bad guy yeah you know at the end of the
day
and but he was a tough guy and he in his
one time
his wife was singing and she wasn't a
good singer it was a cabaret thing like
a little shitty cabaret thing and and
he probably paid for it right he did so
he's all there and he's and his
his wife is like i've been amazing
and of course there's a couple there's
like a yuppy good looking couple and the
guy
starts talking to his wife and he's
saying anyways do
and so his uncle who's in his 70s at the
time goes like this comes up and goes
hey hey
[Laughter]
so the guy goes all right anyway so
we'll go to the thing
and and so his uncle comes back and goes
like this he goes
hey
short hit him
so that's what he would do so he was he
wasn't a jokester
so jimmy jimmy one day we're all
everybody's just sitting around at
dinner
and jimmy starts going so ask me a
question ask me about
if i've been going to long island lately
let me go to long island
yeah you know what i i haven't been i
haven't been because uh the train
doesn't run the way i wanted to and
his sister's laughing so hard and he
goes and he asked him another question
he goes like this he goes
all right so what else you've been doing
still a lot of acting trying to get some
uh voice over work
he goes how the [ __ ] is he [ __ ] sharp
he's talking like that he's and finally
he already just goes hey listen you
[ __ ] fish
hey listen you [ __ ] fish mouth i'll
give you a shot in the jaw cut this [ __ ]
right i love the way he would [ __ ] with
people man
that's because you're a big stupid [ __ ]
that's because you're a goddamn [ __ ]
[ __ ]
at least the ladies had a fun time with
it dude you could have went a hard
laughing
he could have got canceled in the night
it's all
he would love he would love when we go
out he would love we'd
tell his grace to be at the bar on the
way the bartender you guys want a drink
can you go sweetheart do you want
something oh you want like that i go
get the [ __ ] get off my head don't do
that
and he just sometimes he would tell him
when i wasn't listening you go we live
together we've been dating for a long
time
next thing i know you know [ __ ] you
seem like such a
i didn't know you were a couple i'm not
i'm trying to pick this girl up
hey you don't tell bad stories i don't
tell many stories absolutely
just in general oh yeah i don't think
i've ever heard you tell a bad story
i don't know i don't really tell stories
i feel like i just think it's funny how
like patrice thought like women just
don't tell bad stories
stevie doesn't really tell bad stories
either to get stevie to talk
you got to get it out of him well like
all like when i got really
really into the winter hill gang and you
know all that [ __ ]
um i would text him like bars and stuff
that uh
whitey bulger would be at and steve like
yeah it's cool no i know it's cool tell
me
if you've been there and give me the
[ __ ] details dude he knows
you gotta get it out of him stevie knows
i mean i remember one time
we after our show stephen was like
boston
let's go that's from yeah restaurant and
stevie he's kind of opened it for us
he was like hey what's your p's and q's
here like don't don't stare at him too
much don't say
i'm just going for a steak dude i never
got when you walked in
you walked in there all the good fellas
were at a table here right when you
walked in they still hang out if you put
them in a movie the director would be
like it's they're too spot on too
spot-on
it's exactly how you're looking tough
like good fellas like we walk in and see
if he's like they're gonna be to the
left they own it
just don't stare at him just we'll just
go sit down just be cool you know
and and meanwhile he's like just be
normal they recognize you right away
yeah right away
they're like guys wait so they they all
still hang out at these like this bar
well those
suits and it's boston so there's a whole
but it was funny when he walked in
because they don't they're not gonna
notice me
but guys like that will notice fighters
they'll notice ufc fighters
they they'll they're not gonna they're
not gonna they're not gonna come and go
can you get your autograph for a picture
of that [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] how
did he talk the two guys i've known the
two types of dudes i've noticed that are
never
impressed with you the way other like
when you were fighting or other people
like
okay when you're [ __ ] actually it's
it's seals those special forces guys
uh gangsters gangsters and including
that is motorcycle gangs
and motorcycles they like it but they're
not gonna be like oh can we get a
picture now oh really like
like when i did shows in indy like all
the hell's angels were there i was like
[ __ ] and they went in line in the vmp
line they're in the back i'm like what
the [ __ ]
i'm like oh you want a picture and they
all had their healthy like no they don't
picture you just want to say what's up
man
oh yeah yeah they're not they're not
they're
we own the uh strip joint up the up the
way man the the
the birds are sucking the boys off if
you and your brother want to stop by
what the birds are sucking the boys
let's just say there was one guy in that
group i don't know any i was like
you know jj's like yeah where's the
address and i was like we're not
going there i'm not hanging out with
hell i'm sure it's a great time but
one thing out of line man i'd be
terrified to kick it with people like
that
well it's like that our friend who said
it's that i was i never forgot what he
said he goes
i said what's it like what do they like
to hang out with he goes grizzly bears
good guys grizzly bears though yeah just
understand that you're you're not a
grizzly bear mm-hmm
so you're in you're with grizzly bears
you can study grizzly bears you can be
around them
they might get used to you but you're
not a grizzly bear so don't act like a
hell's angel
well did you you start thinking you are
it might be a guy from another chapter
who comes in that clubhouse and punches
you in the face well did you ever
there's that book called under and alone
it's a fed who goes undercover and he
gets
so deep and being held above so deep
he starts doing drugs with him and even
the the government's like dude you're
too
involved he started doing drugs that's
why everything else they had to pull him
out of the
well if they threw everything out
because he actually did drugs and all
this [ __ ]
i'm sure you get i'm sure but he was
saying he was saying he was there
and uh uh he brought a friend with him
and
the hell it was like not the hell's
angels a different biker gang but
they're like mixing i guess they're like
a branch of the hell's angels they went
to a house party and you know there's
girls and stuff like he's like
don't talk don't take anybody's girl
don't talk to girls and don't get drunk
do not get drunk at this party yeah well
his friend gets
black i mean [ __ ] up they started
giving shots gets [ __ ] up and they
just beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah
they all just why yeah he was cause he
was there he was a sheep among grizzly
bears and got
got like got too comfortable yeah you're
not going to be
it's it's funny i i i have a theory on
that too because one of the things is i
think that the allure to that isn't just
the
the freedom it's the freedom but also i
bet it's the bonds you make with other
dudes in that world
where you're always taking a risk in one
way or another well people think about
it
we'll see where they came from so all
those bike gangs started after vietnam
because they all came back and they
didn't that's where yeah they didn't
belong anything and sonny was in vietnam
and he didn't have the camaraderie
and they didn't have like that that bond
so this biking they got it there
so being in the trenches with your boys
then being the trenches here in america
with all these biker games
yeah and that that's that's a type of
dude too that's it that's a that's that
same it's a warrior it's a warrior
mentality there's
there are warriors in the world like i
really love that the idea that there are
there are people who are warriors what's
that what is that prototype
warrior magician lover that's like there
are artists
in the world and and then there are yeah
warrior magician lover king
it's really true like you you are born
into a certain type there are certain
archetypes that you
are and the idea that when if you are
i'm a magician i'm a comedian i'm an
artist i'm a [ __ ] jackass i'm never
going to be a warrior i've always wanted
to be one you're not going to be a lord
either
no i'm not a lord either but either is
he
go to go to four male archetypes
it's a really interesting idea because
you know
warrior magician and lover um but in
order to have
uh magicians and lovers you need the
warriors to fight
100 percent freedom and to protect
individuals and what is this saying
you need warriors to protect the walls
and sometimes when you're a warrior
you don't have anywhere to put your that
warrior energy so you find an outlet and
it could be
in a bike or gang it could be in the
seals it could be in in the cage
but it's a type of it's a type of person
a type of man it doesn't mean you don't
suffer from fear
it doesn't mean you don't you're not
sensitive it doesn't mean you're not a
bad a good guy
when it comes to being a warrior it's
just that you are it's a different thing
oh it's a really interesting idea i love
i love the whole idea
this is a book because it helps you i
wish somebody showed me this when i was
a young man
because what what i remember a friend of
mine was a really intelligent woman said
stop trying to be a tough guy
your masculinity comes from your humor
it doesn't come from you being
a martial artist or whatever you're
trying to be
and it was a huge turning point in my
life because you didn't listen but yeah
i didn't listen
i didn't listen but i did though in a
way i became a comic yeah
i mean i'm still very tough and i'll
keep you busy and we all know that my
hands are heavy
when's the last time you you've been in
a fight i mean all the time dudes
i mean i've straightforward you've never
been in a fight a street fight you've
never been in a fight
i'm you've never been in a fight i have
been and i have a short temper and
i fought him a couple times in this this
i'm not talking about him
i'm talking about like a person you
don't know y'all had
some beef and just boom yes no
i haven't have you sh i've heard his
have you
my last fight was i was 15. when you're
drinking and [ __ ]
um no no my last
like last time i actually like hit
someone i was 15 years old now with
everybody who has
cameras on their phones yeah find the
upside to any situation you're gonna get
sued
people just never really [ __ ] with me
though people always thought like i was
just like
athletic doing backflips and drinking
who would yeah
you know backflips yeah like i never
think about
uh the only time i'm ever gonna get in a
fight if somebody's [ __ ] with
somebody who can't defend themselves
yeah yeah yeah it's so [ __ ] to my kid
that that would be that's what i think
about kyle do people pick on you
with a mustache and [ __ ] no i never got
picked on because i
i was the comedic relief for the entire
high school i normally made everyone
laugh
and no one really wanted to [ __ ] with me
he's an artist magician
yeah so i weaseled my way out of stuff
and you know i picked the the right
crowds to run with they had bigger kids
in it
because hey he took my lunch money and
then they would go get you know 50 bucks
back from the bully and
yeah i'd have lunch but my son's a
magician my son's like i got my energy
he's funny the kids love him
and he's just funny and silly and he's
just skinny and tall and just
and he doesn't like violence like i he's
this is this different kind of body
i would always get hurt i tried to play
football as a disaster for me i was like
i get hit by dudes like you i was like i
can't do that was it made for the only
thing i quit yeah i was like
i just can't you tried football yeah but
it was too i would it would be cold in
new england these guys were all too big
i just wasn't billed for it right
but my son has a friend and he's our
neighbor and he is a
[ __ ] tank and i when i tell you it
doesn't feel pain or temperature
like he just jumps and he's just not
cold he doesn't everything is just rough
and he just
only feels good grabbing and throwing
you around and the mothers how old is
the kid
ten but he's just a natural tough guy
he's
a boy's boy yeah a boy's boy like just
only into sports and everything else
and his mother and i'm sorry not his
mother but the other mothers were
talking about how
he's a terror and he needs to be he's
rough and he needs to be scolded and
they're trying to tell them i said guys
their kids are [ __ ] he's a warrior
that's his natural energy
you need he's not a bad kid yeah you
have to take that energy and put it
that's just what it is that's yeah yeah
you got it you got it you got to put it
in the right place but don't scold it
out of them yeah
it's going to find an unhealthy you're a
warrior
yeah a christian was scrappy yeah you're
a little scrappy one yeah he's
you getting fights uh the last fight
i've been in like a week ago
well like of someone i didn't know
really like i've like i'll get in fights
with my brothers all the time but
they'll didn't your brother hit you with
like a frying pan or some [ __ ] he looks
no he's cool and i went to block it with
the frying pan he punched a frying pan
and it
[ __ ] my face up things are really
sharp but uh
the last fight i think i got into was
senior year of high school
like so like like four years ago yeah i
had beef with the guy that he'd pulled
up to his house with his friends i had
my friends there
got into a huge bra story yeah it was it
was wild it was like the weirdest thing
yeah they actually did they had a
leather jackets they came out
snapping like one of them had like the
little switchblade yeah i was like i
don't know if i know what was going on
yeah who fights these days yeah i think
i think
i'll tell you i think a warrior is who i
choose in my [ __ ]
in my platoon or in my foxhole any day
that [ __ ]
oh yeah you're a warrior chin one
hundred percent
one hundred percent if you had if you
like playing the whole time in the whole
body you complain but if it
if it came down to you if you change one
thing in the hole oh
that's true that's twigs i don't blame
you actually
that precision works in military yeah so
if you're like if you had if you had to
like
fight another group of people to the
death and you threw a gun he can live
off
canned tuna so that's good
[ __ ] in here all the time cheese you're
like sardines and you would have
you'd have the gum you'd have the guns
and all those knives me too
you'd carry all the [ __ ] right i'm a
lord
one of these it's somebody that says
you can show me that [ __ ] but i'm
going to change that on the right
official document look at the stamp of
the brew
i'm taking a sharpie i'm a lannister no
i'm taking a sharpie i'm going to
scratch it out
that's legit get that [ __ ] out of here
get that [ __ ] out look look at the seal
look at the top
seal what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that is some
dude what did they call that again uh
it's not even
you can't it's not even in it it's
pixelated
what a shitty scene i call it a crest
right you have the crest at home
yeah that crest sucks that's framed in
my basement suit on you
uh oh yeah on my ribs you pack mule
you're gonna carry all the [ __ ]
i'm your lord that's what the lord does
respect yeah he's gonna have to know oh
we need we need like a lord we need a
bunsen burner we need rice he's gotta
carry all the food in the water
here's a lot of weight as your lord you
know you're gonna do that foxhole
you can keep your mouth clean and i'm
i'm gonna [ __ ] your mouth when i need to
no i'm gonna dump in your mouth right
now no you're not i'm gonna duck you're
gonna be
gonna be my baby bird hey bro you're
gonna be my baby bird
i'm gonna dump in your mouth no chin's
gonna clap [ __ ] you
i got i got the whip clap every time i
carry my [ __ ]
carry my [ __ ] stop chilling oh thank you
my lord make the fire
carry my tent nope set things up you all
right because
if your testosterone is low you're gonna
have access to your teeth nope so all of
a sudden
on me all the time keep your mouth clean
do whatever you want your booty hole do
your mouth keep it for me i keep my
stiletto okay
and i got covered in mud i'm outside
going down there i go okay
your daddy then you go what's hot sick
of drinking my balls i'm sick of
drinking this
thick sweat do you have any water i go
today you're gonna get water
today the lord's gonna give you water
that's what i mean i'm gonna go
i'm gonna say chin you got any more that
[ __ ] canned tuna and i'm gonna eat
that
and i'm gonna hate hey i'm looking you
know hey piece of [ __ ]
get some berries for the my name is
pieces piece of [ __ ] hey get some
berries from
you gotta give them an actual name so i
gotta go pick back
berries for the boys and watch this and
then get back in your horses i go like
this i go like this i go
okay no you go like this yes me lord
yeah no no okay all right i go the lord
my lord and then right here in my book
stiletto nope
we're not giving you access to any of
that dude really
keep it there do you know where else i
keep it oh you know what you are in my
mud whistle now this is
that's probably season five for you
season five you're my reek
what's a reek eureka this is
[ __ ] eureka it's low on the
earth
yes mr richard i would never be a reek
eureka yeah and and i would i'm gonna
take your nuts
eureka i knew it i'm your lord
don't do that you're my reek don't do
that i love this you're my reek
this is cool don't do that you've just
been demoted eureka and christian
you know when it comes to knives and
guns it doesn't matter about your size
right
and your lordship we neutralize that
right quick hey sure
funny i understand hey keep your mouth
clean no i'll do
i'll tell you what you're gonna take oh
god
how yellow is he oh god oh god he's just
chopped you're gonna take my teeth out
it's the only way to do it yeah pull
each one
give some current events jen this
episode of fighter in the kit is brought
to you by
on it on it supplements kids if you're
gonna be thick that's fine but you got
to do it the right way you're going to
need a little help in the supplement
department
we're talking about the best supplements
on planet earth combat on it
on it.com fighter 10 off the entire
goddamn website what do you need alpha
brain new mood
total gut health key minerals shroom tac
what do you need creatine protein powder
protein bars protein bites we got it all
we got coffee
we got fitness for your thick ass yeah
we got fitness
fitness for your thickness onyx
kettlebells audit on-demand workouts
home fitness programs
battle ropes sandbags hydrocor bags
steel maces steel clubs quad maces
we got it all man on it.com fighter
10 off also kids we on the road this
week the crew
is in tacoma washington this thursday
friday saturday
me and the crew chappelle backflip lacey
david lucas
the whole crew will be in tacoma
washington this thursday friday and
saturday
then in august north carolina august
19th through 21st
and then la jolla comedy store la jolla
comedy store
california august 27 through august 29th
that's two shows friday
two shows saturday one show sunday la
jolla comedy store california
but this thursday friday saturday tacoma
yup keep your [ __ ] but even though
hey even though you're a lord he's a
[ __ ] dragon
boom that's a great dragon dude thanks
buddy
you give me more little fan dragons by
the way if you guys want to see the man
dragon tomorrow
ontario improv starting tomorrow friday
and saturday
come get your tickets briancallen.com or
tfkz.com
ontario that's not even our website huh
what's your website what is it
what is it it changed so much i don't
even know anymore ftk
fatkz.com
ontario improv yeah
okay so brendan you want us to bring
this up because simone
biles you guys always put it on me
and you're the one that asked for this
to be on there
i've seen this be i'm kind of confused
about this
i've seen it so she you know she signed
up for the olympics and then when it
came go time
she she didn't do well and then she
pulled herself out of it
and decided for mental health so is she
out of the entire olympics is she still
competing in individuals or does she
just pull out
herself out it started with the team one
then she pulled herself out of the other
one recently
so she's not gonna compete at all i
don't think so wait i thought it had
something to do with
oh cause i heard a lot of weird things
pop off yesterday because she announced
that she was gonna
take a step back and then progressively
as the day went on
it seemed like she was pulling out of
more things focused on my well-being
here's my thing with the mental health
stuff it's like
it's almost become weaponized where now
we're allowed to critique any of this
because well her mental space
cool well you took somebody's position
to get on that team in the olympics
somebody who tried very hard and didn't
make it
and you took their position because
you're the goat of gymnastics and that's
fine
and now you're representing the united
states once every four years
so when you're there you got to be a
professional
and i don't give a [ __ ] what's going on
mental health issues parent died
whatever's going on
as a professional we require you as a
professional to put all that to the side
and bring home a gold medal it's once
every four
years professionals no matter what's
going on with the professional comedian
athlete i'm sure the show must go on i'm
sure there's times kobe bryant feel like
playing basketball
but he has a contract he has teammates
that rely on him
and he got to perform i'm sure he was in
the right headspace
all year but he still performed and now
we've weaponized mental illness where
we can't say anything well she don't
feel like doing it so let's give her a
break
it's the olympics this is the highest
level of gymnastics
my only thing is if we might find out
it's something
where we go oh [ __ ] you know bigger than
that is her brother still
i feel like they keep using like that as
like a
thing that just oh it's mental have you
ever seen i can't we can't stand
she gets done with and she goes i just
don't want to be here i don't i don't
want to be here i don't feel like doing
this i don't want to be here
it's like okay that's fine but you have
teammates who rely on you
now they want you to still have they
support simone's edition and applaud her
bravery
we throw these words around a lot but to
me this is like to me this isn't brave
to me
it's it's she's not performing
she didn't show up for the olympics and
now we can't criticize her for pulling
out
we just gotta go okay she didn't feel
like doing it well i think what you're
saying
we're talking about professional sports
so tom brady gets super ball
and the entire organization's relying on
me is guys i'm not gonna play today put
the back up in i don't feel like doing
it
so we just gotta go okay it creates an
excuse you can't [ __ ] with which would
be
i'm having mental health issues and that
you could use
for anything you know i think there's a
case she just doesn't want to be there
and there's no crowd and surprise shitty
circumstance she's like this sucks man i
don't feel like being here
okay but this is once every four years
the only thing is i'm surprised
that who's so used to training and
accomplishing it is that good
she might be over where this is what
fourth olympics fifth olympics some [ __ ]
like
no i don't think there's that many she
she's no she's not she's been going for
a minute maybe
how old is she now how old is she is
currently 24.
yeah so she's probably been in the
olympics since she was 16. is that is
that how old she's
how many times 30 olympic and world
championship medals
no uh what was that most decorated
american gymnast of all time four four
four times so i mean that's
that's a lot full-time olympic gold
medals yeah but i don't think she's been
has she been in four olympics so she
started when she was 12.
oh the four-time olympic goal oh yeah
yeah she's the ghost
here wow um i i just think yeah maybe
she's over it maybe she maybe she is
having a
she had a nervous breakdown that could
that happen
you know that happens so i don't i what
is going on with her brother
there was a big story about her brother
getting into some trouble recently
yeah i don't remember yeah it was
something serious okay very serious
oh [ __ ] i mean i don't know man i don't
know her i don't know what she's going
through
but i do i do i do think that
it's it's worth talking about when you
when you pull out for mental health
reasons
and we we say automatically you're
that's brave
we could say that with anybody at any
time who does this so this is
my only thing when certain things are
untouchable my only thing is when your
team's relying on you like in your
profession if this is
a normal run-of-the-mill competition
she's like i just like before
yeah fine once every four years you
don't have the mental capacity to
push whatever you're dealing with aside
and perform for your country
yeah it's very strange especially
for hers you talking about the goat yeah
i wonder if there's there's got to be
more to this story
right i feel like that too documentary
through eight years from now and we're
gonna be like oh [ __ ] that's what she
knows she just said i don't feel like
being here
and then she said i don't keep doing
this and then really injure myself
because i'm not focused
that's what she said or pr probably
could have
helped her say that her publicist or
whatever no she
dude i'm telling you she's she gets off
the stand she like doesn't do well
and the coach comes up she goes i just
don't want to be here damn
let me see this this was it no let's do
an 18.
it's weird because of her prior
achievements right like she's
yeah the best to ever do it
dude they had to make a skill illegal
yeah yeah to make something illegal
because no other girl could do it
goddamn
but but my only thing is at this level
like
how much leeway do we give people so
again if tom brady gets the super well
share
and then goes guys out i'm just on the
right head space like
oh we just gotta be like okay cool i
mean she compete
when she's 28 she could you could if you
qualify but i think
there's a the 44 spans she's like one of
the greatest
cut off damn really can i see that a 44
year old female
[ __ ] and all these girls got picked up
that was like a couple olympics so
technically she could so technically
qualify there's no age limit if you
qualify there's just an age
minimum 46 year old gymnast 40 46
8th olympics well she hasn't grown much
good god it's got to be hard in your
body
oh dude all that tumbling [ __ ] is it's
insane
i mean right on the body i mean that's
an intense human being let's go to
images for a sec
they're all so tiny yeah
tumbling stunts your growth well she
looks like kyle in that [ __ ] jon snow
she dies the third picture
how about being 46 and doing that stuff
though yeah
that's interesting i mean if your body
can still handle it that's [ __ ]
amazing because
that should does not feel good would you
have to do some
stuff for that i don't know i don't know
if you could
how do you stand because you don't want
to you don't want to be i don't think
you want to be big for
she i don't think she's meddled though
just for
that's incredible dude that is just
[ __ ] incredible
yes so simone biles could easily perform
when she's 28 and 32. i don't think she
wants to dude she doesn't want to do
this one
she's 24. she's just done
i mean she's been doing it for so long
you know in your whole life i was
watching that documentary on
naomi osaka she's number two tennis
player in the world yeah
and like you i love tennis so i've
always said i'd love to be a pro tennis
player it just seems so amazing
well okay when you're you've been
playing since you were three
and you spend literally eight hours a
day on the court sometimes
six hours like all you're doing is
tennessee makes 80 million dollars a
year i understand
but i can understand how people get
burned out i can understand how people
have been doing it
injuries and all that yeah that's fine
then don't go get a regular job let me
know how it goes right
get a regular job don't go to the
olympics and represent our country yeah
and then back out on your team that's
why i only feel like the
the teams depend on you they got silver
for the first time what
i hear i hear what you're saying in a
vacuum i just think
she also may have a very good excuse or
she just can't do it mentally maybe she
had a breakdown
maybe she had a real breakdown i don't
know yeah i mean everybody can handle
that i mean that's a professional
you're held to a different standard
we're not talking about
a regular competition you're talking
about the olympics
the creme de la creme of all the world
everybody competes there
you took another girl's spot to get on
that team
that girl's like well [ __ ] man i would
have been down to do this
yeah i don't know what to say about it
it's tricky i just don't i don't and
you're really not allowed to even
criticize it i'm not criticizing her
she's the best of all time i'm just
saying
a little bit but i understand it's it's
it's it's tough because the olympics
yeah yeah i mean i i think
i think a better way to say is that if
if you're doing this it i would hope you
have a very good excuse that's a better
way to say it maybe yeah
agree right yeah like if you're doing
this then i hope you have a
[ __ ] really good excuse because if
it's just out of context
yeah then that's that's that's not great
or
if she's like mentally i'm worn out it's
like okay
but it's the olympics you represent the
united states so
this sounds like a personal issue and
you're a professional you make millions
of dollars a year
representing you know women's gymnastics
yeah now if it's amateur all right cool
miss it i don't give a [ __ ]
but you're talking about the highest
level competition like there's
there's fighters who don't feel like
fighting that night there's there's nfl
players who don't feel like throwing the
football but
you're getting paid a lot of money
there's a lot of people depending on you
yeah you're a professional for a reason
yeah i agree um
is there a punishment for miss miss yeah
you don't get on this metal chin
[Laughter]
that's it yeah she's not going to get a
medal
i mean i don't know what they're going
to do she's the face of gymnastics
but they probably won't do much to her
because they said the mental health they
can't
it's too dicey if you see anything on
the topic if
you say you know mental illness is just
the only thing i'd say about this that i
felt weird is like she mentioned
that she didn't think she's going to do
well so she
left and then she also decided the
mental thing but she
was she wasn't performing well yeah she
was not watching and they said even her
warm-ups she wasn't doing good yeah
and then so she did exactly in the
warm-ups what she did when it counted
and she was like i just i don't want to
be here that's the thing that kind of
bothers me everyone's like what the [ __ ]
because imagine imagine you're like i
think of like my own self
if i'm doing a show and the last minute
my my guitarist or lead singer
bails right and there's all these fans
in there to see you
you messed it up for everybody i mean
i've never in in my
that's why they all yeah just you know
they should be happy they got silver
it's like yeah but we're supposed to get
gold because you're the best player on
the team
and we're a team so if you do well we
all get gold in my 26 years of being on
young stage or film or tv i've never
once in never missed a performance even
when i was really sick even when i was
same never ever ever do when i got much
can't ever do what i've done
yeah never missed a podcast in eight
years dude that's amazing
dude [ __ ] you it rhymes out
half the time when i uh went to compete
for the world title
that was when i found out about my
brother dying yeah i didn't know your
brother died
yeah i did 2013. but yeah that was when
i heard you're you're
we uh you grew up with your brother i
don't know anything about him you don't
know anything about me
right now lord you so clearly didn't
listen to the podcast while you're on
break
yeah did not yeah interesting
sure but i mean i didn't know you know
like so did you pull out
no i competed it was the world
championships it was the world
championships
but there was a lot to it that i like
thought about it was like okay
i can't go home and do anything what am
i gonna do at home
yeah you know if i fly back home he's
already gone
yeah so i was just like why don't i just
[ __ ]
go out with a bang do your job do do
that and
it was just the fact that like you know
another thing to it was like
you know my brother was the only person
in my family that ever saw me compete
yeah so it was just like
it just made sense to do you better and
then yeah and
yeah of course he would have totally
your older brother or a young older
brother two we were two years apart
but it but like it would have made you
know total sense for me to like
i don't feel bad about like doing the
competition and like
you know plus my whole team was like
great to me the whole time
and [ __ ] you know we you know we took
gold and they're probably counting on
you they're probably counting on you too
yeah if you're not there
there's a lot to do i mean you know so
what's crazy is my coaches were like
we'll get you the first flight out of
here you know we'll get you the first
flight
out of here you know back home like as
soon as i found out about it
and i was like no yeah i'm gonna compete
you know
what else you got jen i mean cat you
you're around mental
illness and like depression stuff i mean
you probably have a different
perspective
uh i feel like every time i've had to do
something i just kind of block [ __ ] out
i've numbed myself for a long time so i
just as long as i get the job done
i deal with my emotions later but then
like that's not good for me
so it's some people handle the
difference yeah different people just
handle
pressure house think sometimes if you
have an out and you can get out
sometimes that's a very tempting thing a
lot of people just don't have the option
of going anywhere
yeah but it was i mean for me there was
just something about just doing the
competition
sure there was something like you know i
felt more power in that you guys were
close you know
yeah you know kyrie irving took uh like
a week or two off
this season for mental health issues wow
because they just need a break
the brooklyn nectar like all right we
okay we get that but and they couldn't
say anything
yeah they asked me a mental break for my
mental health
like okay but we're paying you 140
million dollars
so that the you know i wonder some
athletes other one or some athletes in
the past have always done that
where they were like i don't know my my
knee is just killing me i don't know if
i you know that you kind of fake an
injury
some people just need to take breaks i
guess i don't know
hey jordan played with food boy isn't he
yeah jordan's a whole different thing
thing is it's different right did he
bail during the game or do you
talk to people like i can't play you oh
he didn't talk to him but he just was
like i'm not showing up
so he just didn't go to a game yeah and
he wouldn't do any press or anything he
just stayed in this house and like what
the [ __ ] going on
i need a mental break sounds like yeah
and they're like
okay but you also think the world's flat
listen we paid you
70 million dollars like here's the other
thing
if it's a one-on-one sport cool dude
you're gonna suffer from it take the
break
when it's a team sport and you're the
captain of the team
you gotta put the team first you gotta
perform and we're paying you a
[ __ ] ton of money to perform you're
professional
that's the difference between
professional amateurs amateurs can have
those days off
as a professional you cannot it's like
being an actor or a director
and there are millions of dollars on the
line you cannot
show up you cannot not show up you can't
the whole production is built around you
so if you're an actor
i'll tell you you see this some actors
you can never do it as a director
because that's stopping me but if you're
an actor
and you're a star and you say i'm having
mental exhaustion
or whatever i can't do this anymore and
this is history there's a lot of
examples of this it's all good okay
we'll put this on hold for how long
a week two weeks good okay we're gonna
eat we're gonna eat how much
about a million five million dollars ten
million dollars okay cool
the minute that movie doesn't do well oh
you're screwed
oh you're so [ __ ] oh you're you're
you're in movie jail and you might not
get out of it
because they don't think if you're the
next head coach of the olympics and
simone biles goes oh i won't be on the
team
are you gonna you're gonna go are we
gonna get to the finals and
she needs another break like you know
what do you do
do you do you know you're always on
eggshells now yeah yeah
reliability now her team they do compete
as a team too in the olympics
that's what i'm saying yeah the team's
banking on you it's a whole team
sport like how how you do and score
points
goes into the team totally it says they
were cool with it
well no they they say she's brilliant
what else are they going to say yeah you
have to be cool
i guarantee those girls got in the back
like we're [ __ ] struggling too man
we've been doing us all our [ __ ]
lives and now we're here for the gold
and you're out
i guess when you're that good you know
yep it's hard how old is she
24 she's undeniably good yeah she's the
best of all time but yeah
that's why it's a big deal yeah i don't
know hopefully she's okay though yeah
so kanye west is currently working on
his newest
album which is named after his mother
it's called donda
and while he's finishing up this project
he's actually living
in the mercedes-benz stadium in atlanta
and this is a photo of his room
i don't know why he chose weird music
and there's pictures of him popping up
at events just randomly yeah he has like
the map yeah on the mask and the red
is that what he's wearing yeah this is
at a basketball game i think that's so
interesting
that the kids being like oh that's kanye
west yeah you don't stand out at all
but how do they but actually i wouldn't
recognize him there but i guess he's got
to wear that but that's
is was it is that did that does that
thing come with a siren this guy's in
his is
weird because he did of like the album
release party
yeah i played it for everybody and then
we thought it was going to come out and
then now it's not coming out
i guess you wanted talking about do like
just little tweaks to it before
releasing it but supposed to be his best
work yet
yeah a lot of people who went to the
album party said this is didn't they
would look at this
yeah david lucas went to it you see that
the thing where the
guy snuck in to the release party
as a as a photographer what happened
nothing he just snuck he just he just
snuck his way in he
he uh photoshopped uh the the badge yeah
the badge or whatever
he gets into everywhere doing that oh he
does it a lot yeah he does it all the
time oh [ __ ] that's some [ __ ] stevie
would do
yeah that's insane it's so weird to wear
a stocking over your head like that
[ __ ] he's done it for a while uh his
jesus tour he did that too
this is oh this guy yeah
so i'm walking back to the car to
photoshop it the photo i got wasn't good
enough to use as a source so i had to
make it from scratch the pictures from
the t-shirt that they sold at the merch
booth
took a picture from twitter printed it
out chopped it up stuck it on me
got it on me from here on out it's just
confidence and moving quickly so they
don't get a good look at the passage if
you want
thank you appreciate it like a charm
baby
there are a few more gates to get
through to get to the stage but i didn't
record those
so sorry but i ended up right on the
floor
i also had my professional cameras on me
so security wouldn't think twice
so i figured why not try to get as close
as i possibly could as you can see it
got pretty close i actually had better
seats than kardashian
here are some of the pictures i took i
think they turned out pretty okay
pretty okay this guy's fantastic and
he's a good photographer
follow me if you want to see more stuff
like this that's amazing that he did the
whole concept
and nylon stalking mm-hmm yeah he was
sweating my ass off yeah he's so unique
though
yeah yeah that's a different bird that's
so randomly on dax shepard's podcast
mila kunis and ashton kutcher said that
they don't really bathe
their kids unless they see dirt on them
and that they themselves don't really
bathe either
and it's taken a little out of context
because
they say that they bathe they don't
bathe every day but what the big thing
is they don't like using
soap to get rid of their natural body
oils very often so
they'll hop in the shower every now and
then and just kind of rinse off
but ashton and mila did say they
wash their face every day yeah they like
to wash it and then uh he also says that
he'll wash his armpits and his junk
interesting but mila kunis is from
russia and she said that she didn't have
hot water growing up so this isn't like
a weird thing for her
to not shower every day with the kids
stuff it's weird especially going to
school like you always see the dirty kid
in school
goddamn come on man babies you don't
want to wash all the time because their
skin is so sensitive so you want to
share them like twice a week
oh because their skin's so sensitive i
didn't know that yeah you don't want to
do that so are they getting [ __ ] for
this yeah a lot of people
are calling them dirty basically what
yeah they're not [ __ ] dirty
i mean they probably are they probably
are a little dirty
they're just that hippie dippy family
that's fine i guess
what else you got okay so this
man and his wife left their apartment
where their two uh twin babies were in
the home with the grandma
as well as the father's niece
when they came back they found out that
their apartment unit was actually
on fire and so the grandmother
and the niece were outside the house and
they said they didn't have time to go
get the girls and the house was already
ablaze
so the dad ran inside he couldn't see
like his hand in front of him because
the smoke was so bad but he knew
the um was it kind of like the landscape
of his home so he ran just based off of
memory to the girls room
grabbed them walked out and he suffered
severe burns the
girls had sunburns but they're going to
be fine
that's a warrior he's asking for
donations to help with his medical bills
as well as
refurnishing a new home it is currently
past two hundred thousand dollars
god bless jesus christ [ __ ]
[ __ ] are they gonna be okay
yeah they're gonna be okay everyone's
gonna be okay luckily
oh that little buddy man fire and skin
don't go well that's
terrible okay
thank you so the baby
did not want to say that he did some
rants
on his uh one of his concerts and it
sounded like it was pretty homophobic
let me see if i could actually
i said if you don't get aids put a cell
phone lighter
up i said if you ain't suck dick
in the parking lot put your cell phone
lights up
all the lights went up gear straight
because even my gay fans don't got
[ __ ] aids
stupid ass blah blah blah they don't got
aids my gay fans
they take care of themselves they ain't
got no nasty gay
see what i'm saying this is him
explaining why he said it but if you
actually watch the original video
he sounds you know fairly homophobic
i mean hold on i think it's just a
clumsy way
you didn't show up they've been doing a
health service
lights up fellas if you ain't sucking a
dick in the parking lot put your cell
phone like this let's be real about this
[ __ ]
who's this hype man let's be real about
this [ __ ] now
so the very end he says i'm just keeping
it real so it sounds like he is kind of
homophobic
no but i i don't know i feel like he was
going out a lot of things
it seriously sounds it sounds like a
[ __ ] health announcement like
don't be sucking dicks in parking lots
that's what he's saying that's what it
sounds like
and then the ladies if you [ __ ] smell
like lb lbgqt
community coming after them yeah and
even some of that girl that really hot
girl duolipa
yeah because they have to jump on the
they everybody she performed with them
she performed with him before
you got to gang up because it gives you
social capital
the weird thing on this too is a lot of
people thought it was aimed at little
nausea because he released a music video
recently that was like him
and a bunch of like naked dancers
dancing in a prison scene
and it made a bunch of uh outrage online
and
the baby came out and said this which is
weird because he was on one of lona's
ex's
records as he was coming up so it's just
like a weird day
i don't know i assume oh he also brought
corey lanes out uh after megan the
styling performed and tory lanez
is being indicted for a shoot in megan
the sally and their
foot so she pissed yeah because they all
they were also best friend like they had
songs together
the baby and megan and yeah he uh tori
was in a costume on stage and then right
after she performed
he's like i'll give a fan i'll give
anyone a million dollars if they can
guess who that is
and he took the mask off and it was tory
lanez wait so so
uh toy lane shot megan stallion
allegedly allegedly yeah just uh uh by
accident or we don't know well i don't
know it was both feet
so it's like weird yeah it's a weird
like thing that's a [ __ ] gets
backstage
the baby i'm sure she's especially his
audience there's not giving much to
me no and also look at the very very
last thing he says here
uh this is him explaining why he said it
but he goes if if they have fan of me
they're gonna
be going for some big dog [ __ ] we ain't
just going for nothing even my gay fans
have standing i don't know what he's
talking about yeah
i don't know what he's saying so but
when you say even your gay fans got
standards you're not looking at it
as peers right you're kind of like a
little bit lower than i'm sure
yeah i don't know he's a linguist i feel
like there's so much like there's too
much to look at yeah and it was
impossible to understand when he
explained it too so okay moving on
so there's a south korean network called
mbc it's like one of the bigger
broadcasting networks in korea
and i guess during the time they were
looking at all the people coming out
during the opening ceremony the
different you know
countries they would put stuff that you
normally wouldn't think you would do if
you're trying to like you know make a
country look good
so they actually put pizza for italy
like on the screen
when they came out they put dracula for
romania what
okay there's a bunch of stuff here too
why
uh when they talked about the marshall
islands they
they captioned it once a nuclear test
site which it was
it's fine why'd they do this
it's just trying to be like it's almost
kind of like
yeah but then when it comes to when it
comes to korea i think they did
something really nice
something to make a country look good
but this is more like stereotypical
stuff that you would hear about other
countries you use dracula
for romania look in this world you can't
do anything
that's not considered racist or
outrageous yeah
so as long as you keep bowing
to the twitter noise we're always going
to be living in this insanity
so i mean i mean i think this is insane
i think that's kind of like you should
probably do your homework yeah
yeah it's probably lazy it's a little
lazy
by the way going
apparently a romanian but how stupid is
that
so they apologize obviously oh okay
um all right this is a bummer oh
such a big bump yeah me and chappelle
are big fans of slipknot this is one of
the founding members just like not
he passed away we don't know he just
said he died in this city
died in his sleep yeah that's monkey
from corn
we don't know what it's from not yet no
not yet
watch that love island that that suicide
that's like that
girl that sophie girl i said was 30. she
killed herself too oh really yeah
i was like wait what sophie from there's
been two suicides and contestants and uh
and that main woman i can't believe that
afforded
it's because of the media right well
they're the [ __ ] british tablets
yeah right here she was my favorite what
yeah dude gorgeous she died is she just
she was gorgeous hunger stuff gorgeous
that's terrible
it was likely suicide yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they don't think that slipknot guy
it's not suicide right you just died no
he's dying
i dated somebody who did that to herself
and [ __ ]
and i i always wonder i was i don't know
why i'm talking about this but i
remember
i remember she did something really
weird we went on a date and she did
something
[ __ ] weird and i was like and i won't
say what it was but it made no sense
and i was like huh and i wish i had
kind of said to her what's wrong you
know because
susie can you talk to somebody about
this i know right i'm probably not here
no but it was weird as i said how was
such-and-such and my we had a mutual
friend
she was like she hung herself and i was
like oh
okay cool well why don't we edit that
part out i'll tell you the story
afterwards
or not let me talk to a professional i
mean it's good that people hear this
sometimes too you know no it's true if
like
if you're having a crisis man talk to
someone talk to somebody yeah yeah
let's try somebody little [ __ ] uh this
just made
headlines for some reason joe rogan
taking a 20 minute ice bath
and then men's health is saying yeah i
mentally saying you probably shouldn't
that's too long
i don't know anything about it why is
rogan doing is he that sore
i think he got a new bath uh ice bath he
filmed it for 20 minutes yeah
just you know why joe rogan did that
because he's the most extreme person in
the world
just got done working out i'm going to
try the uh ice bath yeah i'm going to do
it for 20 minutes hopefully
i can get more time he looks crazy yeah
nice
i'm more worried about his face
that's a big head i mean because he's
like you know
his head's big he's doing it for 20
minutes
you're not supposed to do that for 20
minutes it's a long time to be in it
why would you be 25 i don't know
is it 18 why is he breathing like that i
mean imagine
all right 20 minutes
oh oh [ __ ]
is he okay he's good he's fine can't
move
that's good for you okay
uh that was smart
so i just did 20 minutes and one of the
reasons why i did 20 minutes is jaco
sent me
a video of his son doing 20 minutes i'm
like well i guess it's possible
um i think the big thing
is because once i did that it was way
more tolerable
now my whole body is just [ __ ]
freezing
why is he doing this to himself he just
wanted to know how you could do it
jesus can you say brennan that if you're
there for a few minutes you just don't
feel anything yeah your body goes numb
yeah your body goes no
but how long are you supposed to be in
there
like ten ten depending how close ten
sounds crazy already too if you're
if you're in a long time you're an
athlete if you're an avenue
yeah i don't know why you did that
because uh he's competitive and choco's
son
did it it's so funny man
this is just a update on the stuff that
we're talking about before the cop this
is the same cop you're talking about
right
that pull yeah something else he threw
something in there yeah
i mean so i thought he took it from the
front seat and put in the back but
actually
took it out of the guy's pocket and then
threw in the back and even told him like
there's nothing in it so why are you
why are you like freaking out oh so was
it drugs no it wasn't drugs it was just
an empty packet oh weird oh so the guy
was just trying to be
trying to make a viral video yeah yeah
like accusing the cop
of actually putting stuff in there
but they didn't arrest them for drugs
right not for drugs
[Applause]
so he's recording the cop right now as
you can tell
[Music]
fast forward specs of green you're good
[Applause]
what
i got you on camera we're all good
hey bro you just threw that in here yeah
because it was in his pocket and i don't
want to hold on to it
that's all it is all it was is plastic
the other trying to say he's planting
drugs
yeah i can understand you get paranoid
yeah so it wasn't really a good game all
good he was like here we are we're all
on camera nowadays
the end of privacy we're on camera right
now
and i think that is it
i think that's it that's it tomorrow
we're headed to
coma ub david lucas david lucas
thursday friday sighted coma comedy club
with the crew kyle will be there with
his mustache
north carolina august 19th to the 21st
end of the month
the comedy store we back la jolla
california comedy store
is two shows friday two shows saturday
one show sunday it's gonna be tickets at
f a t k z.com or thickboy.com
i'm gonna be in uh ontario ontario
improv this weekend
starting tomorrow thursday friday
saturday get your tickets san diego
california american comedy club august
4th
one show at american comedy club houston
texas improv
august 19th 20th 21 buffalo new york
helium
september 9th through 11th get yo
tickets denver
my mom i'm coming home
i guess dude my lord my mom come in
august 26 brea improv uh october 7th
through the 9th
tampa florida side splitters october
28th through the 30th washington dc
dc comedy law and then later november
17th tacoma
comedy club and then uh november 18th
spokane
one-nighters there it is all right kids
love you